so this person says this was this was a
case in England right try and picture
this happening in the United States on
being informed that a girl did not want
to get married
Muhammad Sahib Akhtar imam of a mosque
said we're talking about britain so
let's not say there are a few radical
muslims do a terrace tonight you still
but mad everybody else this imam said
she's 14 she's 14
by sharia grace of allah she's legal to
be married that is sharia by the way
over 80 sharia courts over 80 sharia
courts in England right now that's
ridiculous
yeah 80 Sharia Courts if you understand
what Sharia Courts basically if you're a
woman feminists should be most angry
about this attack they should be more
mad about this attack than anybody else
you know why because this is a place in
the world where Sharia is already taking
over these attacks are to try and
encourage Sharia the same Sharia that
entirely limits and it entirely
eradicate Sri speech whether it's a car
tube or a woman speaking up after a
poorly made sandwich and you have an
imam here saying by Sharia by grace of
Allah she's legal to get married how
about this we no longer get to use the
term Muslims you don't get to say grace
of Allah because there is no grace of
Allah Allah has no grace Christ is
grateful and I don't even care whether
you're an atheist or you are an agnostic
Christ pacifically allows you to be that
if you believe if you don't believe in
him if you don't believe that there's a
god fine but let's assume that you do
let's assume Jesus did he was just some
psychopath who believed that he was God
incarnate he said it you have that right
and by the way by His grace you might be
saved that's a big different concept as
opposed to we're gonna weigh your good
deeds and your bad deeds and Allah is
going to finally get to decide by the
way not covering up your whole body
that's a bad deed by the way wanting
equal rights women that's a
bad deed by the way free speech that's a
bad deed so every single person who
isn't a radical Muslim gets no grace
from Allah by the grace of Allah is an
oxymoron
and you've seen that happen here in
Paris